bonjour messieurs merci de répondre à
nos questions vient de le voir donc une
dispersion rapide du côté de la
mobilisation anti fasciste on a vu des
enfin nos reporters nous ont expliqué
qu'il y avait des tentatives d'incursion
du côté de denfert rochereau seraient
unis où se réunissent les militants du
mouvement générations identitaire est ce
que vous craignez des éventuels
débordements notamment quand la dce la
dispersion aura lieu aux alentours de 18
heures notamment le le couvre-feu
messieurs 42-16 je vous laisse commencé
à écouter par un spécialiste du maintien
de l'ordre mais ça serait dans la grande
tradition des bagarres étudiante qui
oppose depuis toujours d'extrême droite
et l'extrême gauche
donc ça n'aurait rien de surprenant mais
en l'état
par contre tout ça donne l'impression de
se dérouler à l' inverse de ce que je
vous dis c'est à dire dans le plus grand
calme des deux côtés d'ailleurs votre
réaction mais celle-ci mot génération
identitaire n'est pas connu pour être
une formation violente
c'est une formation qui a des
revendications qui sont durs qui sont
sévères qui sont parfois juste avec des
propos qui par contre souvent dans
l'excès à mon goût mais ce n'est pas une
association violente contrairement à
antifa qui est connu pour intervenir
très souvent sur l'espace public avec
une véritable violence avec l'usagé
d'outils on les voit souvent des
matraques télescopiques lors de
manifestations et je me souviens qu'ils
ont utilisé la violence pelure dégager
la cocarde étudiante lors d'une
manifestation étudiante au début de
l'année
donc moi je comprends que le préfet de
police de paris a été un petit peu
méfiants quant au rassemblement d un
tifa au regard de leurs intérêts dans et
de leurs troubles qui sont très souvent
répété à l'ordre public
en plus si j'ai bien compris ils ont pas
respecté la procédure quand a déclaré
cette manifestation dans les temps donc
il faut pas qu'ils viennent se plaindre
aujourd'hui moi je suis pas très inquiet
du côté de génération identitaire c'est
pas c'est pas une association qui est
pas pour habitude de chercher
d'affronter sion
le confrontant pardon à l'époque avec
les forces de l'ordre à l'issue de leur
manifestation car mon de 16
on vient d'entendre au micro de david
khalifa les deux porte-parole du
mouvement générations identitaire et
notamment thaïs des ce qu'ils font qui a
dit que le ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin je cite n'a pas les
outils pour dissoudre génération
identitaire ses arguments les chefs
d'accusation constitution de milices
relaxer pour cela il y à quelques temps
et incitation à la haine jamais condamné
selon elle vous qui êtes avocat
spécialiste donc de la justice
juridiquement à quoi est-ce qu'il faut
s'attendre
la dissolution il va y avoir une lettre
qui devrait qui doit arriver d'ici
mercredi puisque gérald darmanin avait
donné dix jours à génération identitaire
le 14 février dernier à quoi s'attendre
donc écouter la première chose qu'il
faut constater c'est que les arguments
juridiques qui ont été énoncées que j'ai
entendu sur votre antenne à l'instant
sont très pertinents il ya un premier
sujet le premier sujet c'est de savoir
pourquoi est ce que en france
c'est une décision administrative qui va
décider d'enfreindre la liberté
d'association
c'est le premier sujet sur lequel
j'imagine mes confrères vont se baser
pour contester cette décision puisque
comme vous le savez c'est par un décret
pris en conseil des ministres que l'on
peut dissoudre et sur la base de
l'article l 212 tirer 1 du code de la
sécurité intérieure mais qui en fait
l'héritier des lois de 1936 visant à la
dissolution des ligues
alors ce que l'on peut lire actuellement
dans les journaux c'est que le ministre
de l'intérieur reproche à ce groupe de
pratiquer la boxe de façon habituelle ce
qui me paraît insuffisant et même très
nettement insuffisant et ensuite d'avoir
une communication qui serait
un appel systématique à la
discrimination est une incitation
permanente à la haine raciale
mais cet argument me paraît être
difficilement poursuivi dans la mesure
où précisément l'ordre judiciaire à
l'ordre administratif a régulièrement
relaxé génération identitaire pour ces
mêmes faits
donc si vous voulez tout ça est fragile
et va offrir en réalité à génération
identitaire la possibilité de développer
un argumentaire on répondre à votre
question qui serait de l'ordre de ce
qu'on appelle en architecture la fausse
symétrie c'est à dire à partir du moment
où on a fermé des mosquées où on a
dissout des groupes qualifiés
d'islamistes
eh bien il faudrait offrir parallélisme
des dissolutions en venant dissoudre
génération identitaire simplement
j'attire votre attention sur une chose
une déclaration du précédent ministre de
l'intérieur qui a dit que par deux fois
les mêmes services qui ont rédigé la
lettre annonçant à génération
identitaire sa future dissolution en
conseil des ministres et bien c'est même
juriste avait conclu par deux fois à la
demande de monsieur castaner à l'absence
de fondement juridique à leur
dissolution
donc je pense que pour répondre à votre
question tout ça va se terminer
jeux jeux j'ai assez peu de doute que la
dissolution soit prononcé au conseil des
ministres
et puis après ça la bagarre juridique va
s'enclencher devant le conseil d'état
vous avez parlé du conseil des ministres
où cela est très politique justement
pour parler de la
de la sphère politique la récupération
politique maxime thiébaut vous qui avez
été ex-tête de liste debout la france
aux régionales
vous avez également été encarté au
rassemblement national ou encore chez
les patriotes de florian philippot
d'ailleurs on a vu un florian philippot
présent du côté de denfert rochereau
quid de cette récupération politique par
rapport à tout ça non mais de toute
façon la question de la dissolution de
ce genre d'association a toujours été
politique
l'utilisation de la loi de 1936 on l'a
vu dans la situation postcoloniale où le
gouvernement l'a utilisé notamment pour
s'attaquer à des associations anti
colonialiste donc en fait dans
l'histoire de france et de loi qui a
toujours été utilisé à des fins
politiques
là où je vous rejoins m c'est que on a
très peu d'arguments aujourd'hui pour 10
ou deux générations identitaire mais
d'un point de vue purement politique le
conseil des ministres n'aura aucun
problème à le faire après le wifo est
méfiant c'est je sais pas parce que le
juge judiciaire intervenu pour dire que
génération identitaire n'avait pas violé
la loi pour autant le juge administratif
ne sera pas lié il a maintes fois prouvé
notamment 2006 où il avait rappelé qu'il
n'était pas lié par la qualification du
juge judiciaire
quid de la dimension politique pour pour
répondre à ma question parce que par
exemple également marine le pen qui
demande à ses cadres de ne pas se rendre
à cette manifestation de deux
générations identitaire par exemple
alors que fait enfiler pour lui s'y est
rendu après libre à chacun de se rendent
ou patrons moi je me suis pas rendu à la
manifestation parce que je ne me
retrouve pas dans le combat de
génération identitaire je suis
foncièrement républicains alors
différents jeux croire l'assimilation
républicaine et donc je ne suis pas
d'accord avec génération identitaire sur
énormément de choses je n'avais pas
envie d'aller les soupirs pour cette
raison là bas après la récupération
politique elle a toujours existé
récupération par récupération quand
c'est la gauche qui soutient la gauche
on parle moins de récupération quand
c'est la droite qui soutient la droite
tout de suite on parle de récupération
c'est toujours un discours un peu
marrant moi ce qui me fait ce qui risque
d'être très intéressant dans ce combat
pour ceux ci avaient le npa
en ce moment là la manifestation anti
fascistes de récupération non mais il ya
un truc qui est très intéressant c'est
que il n'est pas certain que tout ce
contentieux ne finisse pas devant la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme
pourquoi je m'explique rapidement
aujourd'hui vous n'avez qu'un choix soit
maintenir l'association soit la
dissoudre
c'est à dire qu'on est dans une dans une
situation binaire et la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme et plusieurs sont
intervenus sur la question des
associations pour dire qu'il fallait
faire une vraie sanction proportionnée
et on pourrait avoir une situation assez
cocasse ou génération identitaire après
avoir été dissous par le conseil des
ministres après qu'une décision du
conseil d'état est confirmé la
dissolution se décide à aller devant la
convention devant la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme et gamme cause parce
que l'état français leur édition de
manière illégale
et ça c'est possible c'est possible
qu'on le voit ça pas été identifié mais
ce serait très intéressant parce que ça
viendrait prouver qu en réalité notre
système tel qu'il est construit la loi
de 936 ensuite le code de sécurité
intérieure sont liberticides et moi ce
qui me dérange beaucoup dans tout ça
c'est cette absence de justice c'est à
dire qu'on a depuis un mois et demi un
gouvernement qui nous dit il faut se
battre contre l'islam radical et en même
temps ils se permettent de s'attaquer à
ce type pointe le problème et il je
pense qu'ils envoient un message qui est
assez mauvais parce que on ne peut pas
avoir 50 ennemis en même temps ça c'est
certain
et deuxièmement il ya un problème de
justice totale parce que génération
identitaire est aujourd'hui dissous tout
simplement rééquilibrer la barque et non
pas sur un fondement juridique et sur
quelque chose qui serait juste et cette
absence de justice crise davantage de
diviser les français et non pas de les
réconcilier
et on risque d'avoir demain de davantage
de troubles à cause d'une
instrumentalisation politicienne qui est
faite par le gouvernement des outils du
code de sécurité entièrement deux sets
je vous laisse réagir je vous avais
envie de réagir mais très rapidement on
n'a plus beaucoup de temps
je rejoins pour l'essentiel ce qui vient
d'être exposé je vais juste enlever une
chose si la cour européenne des droits
de l'homme devaient se prononcer ce
serait pas pour dire que la dissolution
aurait été illégal ça serait pour dire
qu'elle n'est pas conventionnel c'est à
dire quelques mots j'en connais puisque
la dissolution serait parfaitement
légale la question n'a ensuite je vais
d'accord est de savoir si en réalité le
fait que l'ordre administratif se
prononce au lieu de l'ordre judiciaire
sur ce genre de questions est encore
d'actualité en france est conforme à la
convention européenne des droits pour
les le lcd justin nous est très très
très rapidement parce que c'est la fin
je devais terminer ma delhaize jadis
intéressant de toutes façons de l'ordre
alors qu'à rennes et herman est fier en
terminale et éduquer l'ordre
administratif n'est évidemment jamais
lié par les décisions de l'ordre
judiciaire
mais on est quand même en train de
traiter un sujet qui a déjà fait l'objet
d'un débat sur la base des normes
juridiques applicables en droit positif
donc même si l'ordre administratif n'ai
jamais dit et par l'ordre judiciaire ni
le contraire il va y avoir un sujet de
logique interne à l'ordre juridique
français en cas de dissolution et en cas
de débat devant le conseil d'état pour
savoir quelle est la cohérence des
décisions qui sont rendus en matière
notamment d'incitation à la haine
raciale qui est l'argument le plus
sérieux de la lettre envoyée pas s'il
aura ce groupuscule merci à clermont ne
cesse d'avoir répondu à la question je
suis désolé maxime thiébaut on n'a plus
le temps
merci d'avoir des trains d'être
intervenu sur sur notre antenne
j'appelle tous les deux vous êtes
responsable de la commission ouvert des
droits de l'homme au barreau de paris
auteur et ex tête de liste debout la
france aux élections régionales
notamment merci à vous deux